I'm not kidding it's hard for me and I
told you this I said it's hard to me to
like when people come on the show to fit
in watching everything everybody does
cuz I have four children a lot of jobs
but I was in Montana this weekend and I
got to watch it was snowing there and I
got to watch your new movie let it snow
it is so good it is so good it's so cute
it did remind me of Love Actually almost
like a new version but it's like younger
it's like a little different but it's it
kind of reminded me of that do you get
that a lot
yeah it kind of has a nostalgic vibe and
it does feel like it's the updated
version of Love Actually in a lot of
ways because I mean that movie stands
the test of time for a reason and people
love that people love that kind of
format though this is new characters
it's it's very 2019 2020 all the
references that are made are very
current and it's concise
yo yeah besides besides the holiday
aspect it's just kind of a really good
movie so what is it about tell everybody
what let it snows about you want to take
this one sure you know I got this I've
been practicing all morning okay so
pretty much okay I'm gonna try not to
cry so this whole cast is full of really
really awesome young talented people who
I've grown up like watching as well like
you on Mad Men Jake up in spider-man we
got O'Day and just really awesome people
should make from spider-man as well and
they're all coming together for this
like separate but also united love story
about different coming-of-age characters
who my character personally I love and I
can relate to her story because her
mother is going through something and
they have this special bond and they
actually referenced the parents in this
high school movie which is rare they
have parents and they're around
and it's great and I fallen well no I
don't want to spoil anything but yeah
Christmas you fall in showing I fall in
lots of falling in this movie there
actually are quite a few stunts in the
movie if there's a lot of there's a lot
of following but there's John Cusack
isn't it they were like when I came in
there and they're like yeah kind of a
young little thing I was like wait 37 I
liked it it was really good
no but John and Joan are great but John
is hilarious her character is so good
but it's also heartfelt she's very like
heart bone know her legend do you have
any favorite traditions like for
Christmas that you do with your family
is there anything um yeah I do it's it's
a little offbeat a little off-center
love but it's a tradition in our family
and I think it comes from their
traditions that they brought to America
from Peru mm-hmm um it's a little crazy
so what you do is you take you take a
napkin and you tuck it behind the person
who's playing that you tuck it in their
pants like a little tail I'll take a
little tail then you light it on fire
you play a song and they have to shake
their butt and and light like you know
put out the fire before the song is over
or else well before they for their pants
catch on fire that leaves your score
what what is this is this a tradition
are they running from sorry you escaping
a spirit look what it's all in fun
spirit it's all fun yeah it's not it's
not menacing at all it's like but
basically if you don't know how to shake
your butt you can't you can't you know
what
wait do you have any ones that might be
you in here
I mean I'm Irish Catholic so like guilt
I guess I'm Irish Italians guilt follows
a firing guilt what are you reading
pasta to the table that's that's
breakfast well since we were kids my
mom's maiden name is D'Agostino so since
we were kids
we've always said spaghetti and
meatballs Christmas Eve so we still do
and everybody looks forward to it and
everybody comes to our house and we have
a big you want spaghetti and meatball
dinner
that's so you should like her some
garlic bread in there well we do we do
doesn't go with things doing now I eat
plenty when it comes to this bread oh
god I hate man man it's so easy it's
just easier for y'all I can't stand here
right now oh so wait and you also have a
song named puppy right where did the
song come from um so I wrote the song
about this guy I worked with basically
he was very obsessed with the idea that
I was latina and he would learn these
phrases in Spanish that were this he
just was asking to get punched in the
face yeah he's trying too hard I didn't
but instead you know he one day I like
called his name or something I called
him over and he was like no don't call
me that call me papi and I'm like why I
cringed all the way down on my toes and
I say you know I mean I'm gonna write a
song about that because he inspired it
is your tool yeah yeah pretty much as a
father of three daughters just go ahead
and punching - I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this